Io alla vostra età
ero già laureata
i giovani di oggi non hanno voglia di fare niente
mio figlio è già alla seconda laurea
e prende il master tra poco
Mio marito aveva sette lauree
Averceli degli uomini cosi, voi oggi non li troverete mai più
ma è già passata un'ora
Io vi avviso, ragazzi, se andiamo avanti di questo passo
non finiremo mai il programma
dovete lavorare di più e chiacchierare di meno
Uee
Good morning a tutti
Beautiful e brutti
who ha fatto gli homework for today?
Leonardi, parliamo di Catullo... non so, qualcosa, un argomento a piacere
Stuppiello
Allora, voglio sapere, parole esatte ovviamente
Sesto verso del quarto paragrafo di pagina 269
Ragazzi, mi raccomando
Se non capite qualcosa, ditemelo che ve lo rispiego
Che è molto importante questo argomento
è tutto chiaro? avete capito?
eh no, prof, io non ho capito quest'ultima parte
Leonardi, non sei stato abbastanza attento!
Io non te lo rispiego, adesso ti arrangi
Adesso vado in chiesa, accendo un cero e spero di non vedervi mai più
Mi viene da vomitare, da vomitare a vedere questi compiti
Vorrei buttarmi dalla finestra
Ma siamo al primo piano e non mi farei abbastanza male
Friedrich Wilhelm Nieztsche
Ma Kant l'abbiamo fatto?
Che cosa dobbiamo fare?
Chi ha parlato?
Chi cazzo ha parlato?
Siete uno sputo!
La più bassa forma di vita che ci sia nel globo
Non siete neanche fottuti esseri umani
Siete solo pezzi informi di materia organica comunemente chiamata merda
Ragazzi oggi faremo un poeta contemporaneo spagnolo veramente famoso
Lo conoscerete tutti, perchè si chiama Alvaro Soler
E la sua poesia è Sofia
Sueño cuando era pequeño
Sin preocupación en el corazón
Paotasso, dai, illuminami tu
paliamo della Seconda Guerra mondiale nè
ma Leonardi, ma basta con questo telefono
lo sai che non si può usare in classe nè
adesso basta, ma di chi è questo telefono?
prof, guardi che è il suo...
Ma come il mio? ma non dire cavolate
Gianpaolo? Ma lo sai che sono a scuola nè
Allora, ragazzi
oggi, lo so, non dovevo interrogare
ma mi sono svegliata con un mal di testa atroce
e proprio non mi va di spiegare
e quindi... Interrogazione a sorpresa!
*risata malefica*
Siete contenti che non c'è lezione...
dai, fate un po' quello che volete
Ma parlate piano che devo fare delle chiamate
Aw, ma che carini, che dolci
Vi siete messi vicini ai compagni
Apposta per copiare
visto che c'è il compito, no?
Bene, mi spiace, ma vi devo separare, allora...
Stuppiello, vai davanti alla finestra
Così guardi il cielo e ti concentri di più, no?
Santaiti, c'è qualche problema?
No, scusa, prego?
Ascolta, mi sento un po' sola...
Perchè non vieni qua in cattedra a fare il compito eh?
Così ci facciamo compagnia...
Bonjour
alors
Che cosa volete fare oggi?
De Martino? mi hanno detto che ti piacciono le 40enni
lo sai che sono single...
Mo ragazzi
Ma aprite queste finestre
Che non si respira
Ma prof, siamo a gennaio
Ma lo sapete, non esistono più le mezze stagioni
Fa un caldo che si muore
Prendiamo l'arte e la mettiamo da parte
lo ho ancora il senso dell'uomorismo, mica come voi
Basta! Silenzio!
Non ce la faccio più con voi, ragazzi
Non ce la faccio più
La smettiamo, allora?
Mi vien da piangere...
In tutta la mia carriera
scolastica
non ho mai incontrato una classe come voi
Omiodio ragazzi
scusate, veramente, da quando faccio
Tu si que vales e striscia la notizia
Non ho un momento per respirare
Allora facciamo subito l'appello, va bene
De Martino?
De Martino, io te lo dico eh
Quest'anno ti boccio, non me ne frega niente
Non sei proprio bravo, mi dispiace
Iannone?
Ci vediamo a casa, amore mio
Ti aspetto